turning overseas now an effort to throw
britain's prime minister out of office
has failed boris johnson fought off a
challenge by members of his own party
after a series of scandals as ramian
asensio reports johnson's long-term
future is still
uncertain the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
leader was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
with nearly 60 percent of his own party
members supporting him a defiant prime
minister took to the airwaves i think
it's a convincing
result a decisive result of what it what
it means
is that as uh
as a government we can move on
moving on he says means new tax cuts for
the masses and fighting the highest
inflation in 40 years but with more than
40 percent of his lawmakers now clearly
against him being moved out from power
must be on his mind
the prime minister now leads a clearly
divided conservative party broken over
illegal social gatherings at work as
seen in these leaked photos while the
nation was locked down at home in the
height of kovid
after breaking his own law he was
publicly jeered last weekend during the
queen's 70th platinum jubilee
he said i haven't done anything wrong
and he's been proven that he has
he should go
but johnson backers like conservative
member of parliament shailesh vara says
the country should move on
theresa may margaret thatcher both won
their votes of no confidence and yet
afterwards they resigned you think that
could happen here boris johnson is a
winner he has come back from very low
positions in the past
his allies hope as much but boris
johnson's days here at number 10 downing
street may be numbered his critics say
he is badly wounded but his supporters
of course say a win is a win tony
never good 148 members of your own party
vote no confidence even if you get to
stay rami and osenso and london raymie
thank you very much